qui est un pari fait par nrj 12 c'est
l'émission de morandini crime et faits
divers alors ils ont fait des records
mais incroyable il ya deux jours ils ont
fait 240 humilité les spectateurs vous
imaginez c'est entre 12h et 13h jusqu'à
5 bien de 3 2% sur les femmes
responsables des achats
à cette heure ci c'est un vrai pari pour
nrj 12 c'est un vrai succès est en phase
ii et en face d'abord né il ya donc
gilles verdez frente la même émission
seulement en mieux savoir que ces
vielles traditions en france parce qu'il
y avait trois seront repris et bellemare
qui faisait sa joie à la même heure oui
à inventer des histoires de crimes
demeurent stoehr ans et saluer alors
même s'il réussit très bien et sa
réussite très très bien évidemment on
vous a fait un petit résumé de cette
émission qui effectivement que moi je
les aime beaucoup quand je la regarde et
je la regarde ça va parler de la sienne
la sienne alors de la chaîne
la plupart des chaînes proposent des
fictions nrj 12 a fait un choix
surprenant avec une quotidienne
consacrée aux faits divers pourquoi
parce que la réalité sera toujours plus
forte que la meilleure série télé en
prime et faits divers jean marc
morandini raconte et décrypte les
affaires judiciaires à chaud et en
direct cet été dans l'oise une jeune
femme de 34 ans a été tué par le
propriétaire de son appartement c'était
il ya seulement trois semaines
au programme des reportages mais surtout
des témoignages forts en plateau exemple
ici avec la mère d'une jeune femme tuée
par son propriétaire comment vous avez
appris le drame qui s'est déroulé le
mardi en fin d'après-midi lorsque j'ai
vu les gendarmes arriver à la maison
vous avez compris tout de suite des
invités mais aussi des spécialistes
un avocat pour apporter des précisions
juridiques l'homme s'est suicidé
donc ça veut dire quoi il y aura pas de
procès non il n'y aura malheureusement
pas de procès mais aussi une psychologue
pour analyser la personnalité des
coupables
en fait on est probablement l'un face à
quelqu'un qui a une personnalité
paranoïaque avec les milieux divers et
j 12 renouvelle le genre et le pari
réussi mardi l'émission a enregistré un
record avec 250 mille téléspectateurs
alors ce qui est paradoxal c'est que ya
de plus en plus d'émissions sur les
crimes dans les faits divers et je pense
que toutes les émissions quelle que soit
la chaîne ça fonctionne m6 soit sur
vélin sur des histoires là ce lâcher des
500 récente mais comme j'ai une traite
l'actualité barre 60 il n'y a pas
tellement de retours narnia talent du
jour et on va aussi raconter des très
belles histoires de fait divers vous
allez voir vous allez relire 30 jean
marc tremblade valeur ajoutée
le direct et la bande d'experts et je
crois que j'ai lu vous préparé une
petite version nouvelle pour contrer la
concurrence
absolument mais vu la façon dont vous
les empêchez pas si je vais faire